ah tiens voilà franchement christine
kelly voit ce qu'un acteur voilà où une
personne voilà vous avez envie de
rencontrer absolument comme la femme de
benjamin castadi paris où elle s'était
keanu reeves ou c'est qu'ils vous
d'ailleurs totalement mois pendant très
longtemps mais bon maintenant c'était
sophie marceau et dans les bus dans les
petites jeunes celles que vous avez bien
la blonde la subissons n'ont jamais
perçu sud ouest
largo robbie margoni margot robbie
l'autre s'appelle margot robbie vous
déjà c'est beaucoup moins sexy margot
robbie david will smith will smith
j'adore un homme un vrai beau gosse il
joue dans de super film et il ya
toujours des messages dans ses films
j'adore animé ça j'en assure votre
portable aussi des gens me maryvonne
uqam et michel jean marie a il est à
fond sur un tas d'or mais l'italienne
plus peu de tout mais non mais non mais
un ou laetitia oui à l'échelle étendue
leticia costa je crois que c'est sa
fille de croisière oui vous clint
eastwood
alors votre séquence audio si vous
rejoignez il ya fait son retour dans
l'émission depuis deux semaines et demie
et là il est là tous les jours
il est content il est bien il avec son
poteau jean-michel et de ce que ces
titres étaient surtout avec sa femme
claudia qu'on n'en parle genii sur lui
les canaillous vert mais j'ai eu sur lui
quand même
bah oui parce que toujours pareil
l'opération là il sait faire a ajouté m
ici nous l'a dit hier on a eu chaud mais
qui est apparu ce week-end donc la une
mais ce n'est pas par là et apparemment
ça lui a fermé l'oeil alors ses pairs ou
les veut tous les yeux devraient essayer
bon ben je vois comme benjamin alors
c'est qu'il vous ben moi c'est clint
eastwood meet again
non mais je les interviewer voilà
c'était peut être acceptée voilà que
j'ai réalisé voilà tu aimerais la
structure arrive tu me rappelles tu
auras et je me rappelle il dit une
phrase magnifique
il est vrai il ya un moment on dit à
l'inspecteur harry ont dit l'inspecteur
harry rendez votre votre étoile de
shérif libre est inquiète pas je vais te
la rendre cette fin un suppositoire à
cinq branches je me rappelle que j'étais
petit j'étais magnifique sur la tête de
ma mère je vais te fout quoi bien sûr
bob tahri oui bonsoir crédit alors
qu'emi alors déjà oui déjà qui est après
petites révélations sur la fac de
benjamin castaldi et kenz moi ça serait
leonardo dicaprio d'accord et ben il est
là ce soir dans titanic et le loup de
wall street
c'est que le gars il est tout le temps
dans un film à aa
ils voulaient avec lui il a des bateaux
dans les deux mois jeanne et lover vient
de soi vieux et plus mafieux ok ok et
alors et si louis lui que moi rien j'ai
bien fait moi sa maman c'est sa femme
qui clairement amoureuse mais elles
l'avouent elle le dit à son mari dont
les beaux gosses quand c'est avouer on
peut on peut le dire et un jour elle a
tout fait pour le rencontrer rencontre
et keanu reeves qui sera ce soir sur ces
huit dans speed et elle a réussi à lui
faire une interview et c'était plus beau
jour de sa vie non alors web et
relativiser quand même je vous devez la
vérité vraie ville était speed en fait
elle avait vu une voyante suivi tu vas
rencontrer l'homme de ta vie ouais c'est
vrai et en fait elle savait qu'ils
avaient en route avec élise c'est lui
c'est sûr c'est lui et dans le même
temps où elle a vu keanu reeves d'après
elle m'a vu moi et c'est moi qu'elle
n'en avait alors
c'est axa c'est quand même ça c'est un
tel nof où ça va oui le même regard
brille divers éléments m'ont dit faute
de grives on mange des merles et bien
c'est un bon pas c'est une belle
charlatanerie voyant parce que sa
voyante parce que c'est pas comment ça
aurait pu être l'homme de la vie de ta
femme puisque je ne crois pas trahir de
secret en disant non non non ah bah si
tu marques dans notre ami de ma team
non mais c'est le mil le cash que
moyennement donc pardon je dit pas grand
chose oui absolument
j'ai toujours cru que matrix est un film
pour nous battre
vous serez qui veut alors après ces
petites révélations alors en américain
je reste fidèle malgré l'âge batby elton
john
non merde moi contrairement à ses pas
pour une interview
d'accord a dit ouais et sinon en france
est toujours pas pour l'interview matt
pokora sur mcqueen
allez il attend il attend un enfant
j'peux pas d ivoire c'est là mon est
vivant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
navarro jeu coûte
après tu l'as bien oui j'appelle
généraux de mon bureau mais là tu vas
voir oui la barre au jeu quotas dont
vous connaissez pas mon acteur préféré
j'en ai deux autres qui m'intéresse
beaucoup
mais déjà donné nous le jeu qui
s'appelle eddy wideman un grand roue
avec des taches de rousseur et ce dans
les animaux photo alors que j'adore
d'accord apparaît que je connais le
radar connais bien l'entraîneur du psg
leonardo n'en sait pas nager
je me souviens de son nom rouge à côté
lui à la fois quand je vais lui dire tu
as la cote avec une mode de tpm peut
citer non non c'est le badge irradie
badoit jour dans l'autre oui et à aimer
brouillet la brède son style pour pour y
être son style je sais géraldine alors
moi je pense que je demanderai un tête à
tête avec bret easton ellis qui ça
réquista this tony c'est l'auteur le
plus génial génération donc on dit les
commentaires audio de la mefou conseil
white white des white c'est très
important
ils ont adoré voilà blanc n'en sais rien
american psycho à la morale a bâti shaun
ellis et j'adore toutes ses prises de
positions gnioure absolument d'éclat
dont d'accord alors et donc je choisir
un tête à tête à l'heure mais quand nico
est quelqu'un de connu
dans le monde des hélicoptères non mais
il est très connu bret easton ellis toi
et donc et sinon mais aussi non je pense
que je peux je partagerai leonardo
dicaprio mais dans le loser wall street
ouais plus dans le monde wall street
encore une vingtaine depuis ma fille
vénéneux d'accord aux champignons quoi
très bien je frappe ou avec nous
regarder la magnifique en papier alu
j'attends maintenant quoi ça rigolait
bien on dirait une robe de chambre
non c'est bien c'est beau très beau ces
deux médecins c'est de qui aucune idée
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cette cap taniguchi
alors elle donc ouais alors j'ai
longtemps été focus sur ryan gosling
j'ai eu un petit faible pour bradley
cooper dans les star is born
c'est lui qui chante et c'est lui qui
joue c'est vrai moi aussi j'ai vu un
jour il était avec moi finale de roland
garros il ya deux ans il est bien vrai
et il m'a demandé une photo non non je
livrais désir toi et ils bradley cooper
moi je crois que tu es le fils de li tu
vois si j'adore ce que fait t'on père et
tous les jeans et tout et on a discuté
un peu très gentil très gentil gentil
alors attention aux petits problèmes de
peau un bon jeu 10 à l'atterrissage et
les attentions à ça revient il à mais
bon je crois qu'il s'est repris je crois
qu'il est allé chez côte c'est codage
j'avais un petit crème codage tous les
soirs au regard vous avez une belle peau
ah oui vous mettre au compte amener si
si si j'en ai à quel âge à 42 ans
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non je j'ai eu de la cne quand j'ai dit
que j'étais très stressée htc par
l'école par la colère d'ailleurs la vie
scolaire à passer d un million de
téléspectateurs le film alors tu viens
quand on est passé un week-end en somme
en espagne dans votre trousse de
toilette et une brosse à dents et
dentifrice
ouais c'est vrai s'ils n'ont pas un
sérum pas une crème de jour 4 m de nuit
mais schirrhein autour des yeux panne
eyeliner rien rien rien scénario et on a
passé la nuit ensemble est aux baléares
quand on est parti vous savez
directement et il a dormi avec moi file
à dormir dans les locaux un métal il
c'est vrai que le matin lui alors lui
lui ça y est vous explique jeu pour
essayer de téléspectateurs lui ça veut
dire qu'il doit partir de chez lui à 10h
au réveil à 6h du matin et avait décrit
ses pieds à la tête
son parti est grasse et comme au cas où
son père sans rigoler mais son et mon
frère
t'as pas un truc qui dépasse c'est un
truc de ouf son oeil est mon frère c'est
une statue grecque
delormeau et la piste en escrime mister
suisse accorde et on le gagne et tout ça
tout au goût c'est vrai et ouais mais
moi j'étais propre comme attrait ça me
dirait pas en avion s'est fait couper
tous qu'il faut les ouvrir et tout ça
non vous étiez très pop mais il n'ya pas
vous n'avez pas la petite tous vous
mettez pas d'eau de lit avant de se
coucher et là où jamais côté féminin
vous aimez bien un petit peu car ils
sont toujours mon contrairement à toi
mais je veux dire vous vous en donner
ce qui est vrai à l'autre chose a
précisé voyez de transpirer jamais de
bourgeois ne transpire pas alors bonjour
brochot vous venez pour quoi et bien
pour vous dire que moi j'apprécie
beaucoup les chanteuses et et beyoncé la
femme de djezzy oui bon c'est qu'ils
servent des destiny's child et donc
ouais ouais elle a inventé ou je sais
pas vous avez des gens elle a inventé
mêle danse est une danse extraordinaire
le to work
ah vous le savez le faire vous et à tout
faire pour